accueil chaleureux malgré une pluie
incessante clémence et sa roulotte
sillonnent le grand ouest depuis 79
jours et a relaxé jusqu'à mercredi soir
un voyage sur le thème de la via suivent
pour fédérer les enfants autour de
l'amour de lire et d'écrire et de les
inviter à voyager à travers l'histoire
la géographie et puis un siècle de
progrès donc le meilleur moyen de les
impliquer un voyage est un voyage qu'il
découvre par différents moyens notamment
un blog et par des parts d écriture
auxquels ils sont invités à participer
aujourd'hui trois classes rencontre
clémence et son univers magique devant
la grange de l'autre embrouilles
j'aimerais bien faire une aventure comme
clémence ol voyage sur les petites
routes avec des chevaux dans la caverne
d'ali baba des poèmes des dessins des
photos de grand aviateur des ouvrages de
référence et surtout le grand livre du
voyage et la maille ou trésor chacun a
pu y déposer une enveloppe contenant son
rêve c'est dé marcher sur les nuages
mercredi soir clémence et ses trois
juments qui te rend bois d'arcy le fief
de l'aviateur alberto santos dumont
direction saint cyr l'école bucs orly
pour terminer l'épopée de 180 jours au
bourget